ce mois-ci le ticket de caisse du panier
du 20h se stabilise plus 12,9% une
inflation loin du record d'avril dernier
plus
16,98 % à l'époque sur un nom des prix
qui commence à baisser en rayon cette
salarié en doute fortement
aucune différence par mon portefeuille
non plus d'ailleurs Daniel a 64 ans il
est retraité pour faire des économies il
a réduit sa consommation de viande et de
produits laitiers
c'était 150 euros maintenant je suis sûr
qu'il y a rien de 150 euros c'est un mot
qui est revenu plusieurs fois dans nos
échanges sacrifices quitte à parfois se
priver de l'essentiel j'avais goûté
c'est la première fraise de toute ma vie
et je décide de tester de nouvelles
choses soyons fous
[Musique]
là
avec la rentrée pourtant quelques bonnes
nouvelles pour le porte-monnaie certains
produits de Marc voient leurs prix
baisser sur notre liste de courses des
pâtes d'une célèbre référence - 0,9% un
mois soit 1 centime de moins au rayon
hygiène le prix du papier toilette
diminue d'1,5% moins 7 centimes est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui les aspirations des
Français c'est d'abord l'argent je suis
pas sûr c'est aussi
on a fait une heure là dessus
dans leur travail etc et qui veulent
aussi profiter de la vie
on peut pas se permettre de dépenser
plus pour de la nourriture le phénomène
prend de l'ampleur et il est constaté
par les distributeurs
réuni ce matin à Bercy ils s'en sont
inquiétés auprès du ministre de
l'économie il y a une des consommations
ça aussi le ministre la constaté il y a
une vraie des consommations on perd du
volume parce que les prix sont trop
élevés que l'inflation ne s'arrête pas
je serai pas pécheur on pourrait pas
s'offrir 30 euros de rouget à midi et
c'est ça le bonheur c'est de pouvoir
manger le poisson qu'on a choisi il
vient de sortir de l'eau on le mange on
est pauvre
mais qu'est-ce qu'on est riche
j'ai joué avec des Barbies quand j'étais
petite donc voilà
franchement non non c'est pas tellement
Barbie mais est-ce que tu aimes la
betterave
Ken j'adore Ken elle va très bien
l'inventaire
les hostilités sont immédiatement
déclenchées ces combats permettent aux
femelles de ne s'accoupler qu'avec les
mâles les plus forts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
notre mâle a vaincu son rival il revient
se poster au pied de l'arbre
le caleçon qui dépasse du pantalon on
pensait que c'était fini c'était la mode
des rappeurs de 80 ça des années 90
vous êtes très en forme ce matin ça va
être triste je vous avais dit il faut
pas lui laisser la parole
de 400
vous vivez cette vivée ce moment dans ce
cadre magnifique bucolique avec ces
arbres vous pensez à moi et dites-vous
quelle chance on a d’être photographié
par Michel donnons-lui les meilleurs
d'accord on va y arriver
[Musique]
le prétendant approuvé sa force
maintenant c'est une épreuve de patience
qui l'attend
les femelles peuvent rester 6 jours
perchés dans leur arbre
[Musique]
un python géant sur le toit d'une maison
du Queensland en Australie le reptile
d'environ 5 mètres a été filmé par les
habitants une famille qui garde son
calme là où d'autres sur les réseaux
sont clairement apeurés plus de 20
millions de vues pour cette séquence et
peut-être moins de touristes français à
l'avenir l'Australie c'est vraiment pas
pour moi
d'où vient ta point à qui sait attendre
[Musique]
à l'automne la femelle donnera naissance
à un ou deux petits mais elle n'en
élèvera qu'un j'avais déjà des enfants
que ma femme quand vous êtes quand vous
êtes tombés enceinte quand votre
maîtresse est tombé enceinte vous aviez
déjà eu vos enfants avec
même eu un moment où ma maîtresse
c'était enceinte en même temps que ma
femme quoi
est-ce que c'était le moment où vous lui
avez dit
avant alors je l'ai dit une fois ça a
passé mais deux fois vous imaginez allez
le genre de fois disons que j'ai
recommencé c'était pas prévu avec la
même femme avec la même famille
[Applaudissements]
de t'appeler bébé tu diras
avec que je vais
la faire Dream le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale vous laissez
librer les 60 ans du discours de Martin
Luther King pour cela 5 jeunes
reprennent la célèbre anaphore du
pasteur emilitant américain pour les
droits civiques
dès la publication de la vidéo beaucoup
critiquent le manque de diversité chez
les adolescents mis en avant un casting
en contradiction avec le discours
comment notamment cette internaute le
ministère s'en est rapidement expliqué
les adolescents présents dans cette
vidéo sont les lauréats d'un concours
qui encourage la pratique de l'anglais